字幕: Koichiro YODA
校正: Kyoko Kamura
これは 私が15歳の時の写真です
この頃 私は 色々な
悩みを抱えていてですね
今で言う「ひきこもり」
不登校になっておりました
今 思いますと
その時の悩みというのはですね
「人間って何だろう？
自分って何だろう？
自分は特別な存在なんだろうか？」
というようなですね
ちょっと哲学的な原因も
（不登校の）理由ではなかったか
というように思います
それでですね
科学者になった後
先程のような疑問を
科学的に解明するにはどうしたらいいか
というようなことを考えてきました
科学の研究の大切な手法の一つに
「比較する」ということがあります
私の先程の疑問もですね
「何か比較して答えを見つけることは
できないか？」ということを
考えてきたわけです
では一体「何と何」を
比較したらいいか？
私たち人間と「何」を比較したら
いいかということをですね
で 考えたんですけれども
「よその星にも
ヒトがいるかどうか？」
つまり私たちの言葉でいうと
「地球外知的生命」ですね
「地球外知的生命が
存在するかどうかということを
解明する 比較すればいい」
ということが結論になりました
つまり もし よその星に
あまねくたくさんの文明があって
たくさんの地球外の知的生命が
存在していたとすれば
私たちは それほど
特殊なものではない
ありふれた存在だ
ということになるわけです
逆に これはちょっと
証明するのが難しいというか
ほぼ 不可能なんですけど
仮に もし我々だけが
この宇宙にいる
我々だけが知的生命だ
ということになりましたら
私たちっていうのは
唯一 絶対的な存在ですよね？
本当にスペシャルな存在
ということになるわけです
ということでですね
私は 地球外知的生命が存在するかどうか
あるいは「もし いるとすれば
どういう手法によって
発見することができるか？」
というようなことを
追求してきました
では まずですね
知的生命が存在するかどうか
ということについて考えたいと思いますが
その前に一つですね
皆さんに知っていただきたい
ことがあります
これから星と星の距離とか
そういう話をします
星と星の距離っていうのは
非常に離れておりますので
私たちが使っている
キロメートルでやるとですね
０をたくさん書かなきゃいけない
それだけでも大変なので
天文学では別の単位を使います
それは何か？
この世の中で一番スピードの
速いものを基準といたします
速いものは もちろん光ですよね
光は１秒間に30万キロメートル
パッと進んでいきます
それが１年間かかって
飛んで行く距離
べらぼうな もう想像を
絶する距離ですけども
これを１つの単位といたしまして
これを「１光年」といいます
じゃあ その１光年って
私たちがよく使っている馴染みのある
キロメートルに換算すると
どういうことになるかというと
実はですね
［１光年＝10兆km］
これだけキロメートル
０を数えなくていいです
たくさんだなと思ってくれたら
それでいいですよね
これからなんとか光年って
出ますからね
０がたくさんついていたら
キロメートルに換算しているよ
と思ってください
それでですね
じゃあ この宇宙というのは
大きい望遠鏡を作れば作るほど
遠くまで遠くまで見えるかというと
そういうわけでありません
もうそれ以上は 絶対に
見えないっていうところが出てきます
宇宙にもやはり
地平線みたいなものがありますね
これが宇宙の地平線です
それは もう原理的に見えない訳
ですけども 絶対見えません
「ここからその宇宙の地平線まで
何光年離れてますか？」というと
実はこれがこれだけ光年
［宇宙の地平線 130〜140億光年］
ちょっとよく
わかってないんですけど
およそ130から140億光年くらい
だと言われております
それより向こうは
絶対見えないんですけど
じゃあ その中に星 恒星は
いくつあるかといいますと これが
［星の数 ___ 個］
よく数の多いこと星の数って
例えますけど 本当の星の数ですよ
本当の星の数
［星の数 10×22個］
これだけ個
（笑）
これは どの講演に行ってもね
皆さん笑うだけなんですよね
ちょっと想像を絶しますでしょ？
地球上のありとあらゆる海岸にある
砂の数をイメージしてみてください
その数よりまだ多いと
言われています
（笑）
これだけあれば
どこかには存在するはずです
これだけのたくさんの星があって
知的生命が私たちだけだっていう
考えになると
これは 中世ヨーロッパ
暗黒時代と同じような考えに
陥ってしまうのではないか
というように思います
じゃあ「どうやって探したらいいか？」
という話をこれからいたします
こういうことは
あり得るでしょうか？
（笑）
こういうことを考える方はですね
はっきり私たちから
天文学者から言わせますと
宇宙の広さを
舐めてかかってます
（笑）
なんでかって言いますと
太陽系に一番近い星って
じゃあ 何光年でしょうか？
［４光年］
実は ４光年です
４光年って言われても
ちょっと皆さんピンと
こないかもしれないんで
宇宙全体を1000億分の１に
してみようと思いますね
するとどうなりますかね
宇宙全体を1000億分の１に
するとですね
実は太陽っていうのは
地球の109倍の大きさがあります
その太陽がですね
実はこれになります
ビー玉ですね
これが太陽です
本当は黄色いです 黄色いけども
まぁ 今 ちょっと青いやつでね
青いビー玉でやります
これをですね いいですか
ここに置きますよ
ここでもないし ここでもないし
ここに置きますね
いいですか
止まっておいてくださいね
するとですね
もう一つのビー玉が
ここにあるんですね
これが一番近い
４光年先の星だと思うわけ
本当はこれも黄色いんですけど
今は赤いやつでやります
赤いビー玉でやります
さあ どこに置くと ちょうどいい
スケールになると思うでしょうか？
皆さんどう思います？
こことか あそことか
あそことかね
今日は ちょっと答えを
もう言ってしまいますけど
答えはですね いいですか？
（笑）
ここ（神戸）に１つビー玉を置くと
東京にまで行かないと
次のビー玉は出てこないんです
宇宙の星と星の間隔というのは
こういうもんです
ざっくり星と星の
平均的な感覚はこういうものです
もし皆さんが
「宇宙ってどういうところですか？」
って聞かれたらですね
模範的な回答は
「何もないところ」って
答えるのが模範解答ですね
たまにポッと星があるだけ
ましてや 知的生命が
存在する星って
遥か想像を絶する
彼方にあるはずです
ということでですね
こういうことは
絶対にありません
なんか乗り物に乗って
やってくるということは
絶対にないわけでございます
つまり 直接的に出合うことって
いうのは 絶対無理です
じゃあ どうするか？って
これ間接的に調べるしかないんです
彼らが出している何かの
間接的な証拠を見つけましょうと
こういうことしかありません
よくやられているのがですね
彼らが出している電波を
キャッチしましょうということですね
それから 彼らがレーザー光線を
出しているかもしれない
そういうものをキャッチ
しましょうっていう方法
この２つが主な方法です
ちなみに これ
うちの大学の天文台の望遠鏡ね
じゃあ そういったもの
電波だとかレーザー光線ってのは
この地球に本当にやってくるのかどうか
「微弱でやって来ないんじゃない？」って
思うかもしれないんですけども
向こうの方々 っていうか
知的生命が
少なくとも地球人レベルで
あったとするとですね
計算するとですね
電波やレーザーは
数千光年先からでもやってきた
レーザーや電波でも
地球側でキャッチすることができます
電波になりますと
周波数によりますけれども
ある周波数だと
１万光年先から
やってきた電波でも
現在の地球のレベルで
キャッチすることができるわけです
まあ 根拠があるということをね
知っておいてください
では 私が実際にやってきたことを
本当にダイジェストで
紹介したいと思いますが
私が今まで一番
何をしてきたかというと
今 言ったように
電波観測もしました
それからですね
あ！これがレーザーですね
レーザーをキャッチする
ということもやりました
どうするかというと
普通の光線が出す光っていうのは
どの色も均一に出ます
でも もしですね
レーザーが来たら
たとえば 緑のレーザーが
向こうから来たらですね
虹の中に緑のところだけ
光るわけです
グラフでやる場合 そこだけ
ピッと強度が上がるわけです
こういう感じね
それからですね
そういうレーザー光線が
もし来るとしたらですね
知的文明が出している
レーザー光線が来るとしたら
「彼らは何色のレーザー光線を
使っているだろう？」とか
これ世界で初めて
理論的に予測しまして
そういう論文も これ
つい最近の話ですけども
書きました 出しました
それからですね
ある星をターゲットにして
世界５大陸 15各国
29機関が合同で観測する
そういうプロジェクトもですね
私が主催いたしまして
格好いい言葉で言うと これ—
これ私ね
私が主催したんで—
格好いい言葉で言うとこれ
ミッションコントロールセンター
もうちょっと平たく言うとこれ
私のいつもの業務の机なんですけども
（笑）
まあそういうことも
それからですね この日本では
この分野では 一番大きい
研究会をいたしました
で もし見つかったら関係者は
どう対応していいかという
実は 国際的な
ガイドラインがあります
で そのガイドラインがですね
現在のこの時代に見合ったものか
どうかっていうのを検討して
来たるＸデーに備えて
心の準備をしました ということです
じゃあ そうやって
色々やりましたけれども
「じゃあ 見つかったのか？」
これが皆さん一番聞きたいことだと
思うんですけれども
こういう私の観測
研究を含めてですね
50年以上にわたりまして—
他の国も合わせてですよ—
50年以上にわたって
100以上のプロジェクトが
今まで実施されていますが
残念なことにですね
明確な証拠っていうのは
今のところ
［明確な証拠は］
［ない］
ありません 残念ながらね
じゃあ それを以てしてですね
「やっぱり じゃあ
いないんじゃないか？」と
「存在しないんじゃないか？」と
そういうわけではないんです
まだ たったの50年しか
観測してないんです
人類の歴史 宇宙の歴史に
比べたらほんの僅かです
例えればですね
海の水をバケツで１杯すくって
そこに魚が入ってなかったから
やっぱり海には魚がいないんじゃないか？
というようなものじゃないでしょうか
でも これ実は発見があったんですよね
海の水をバケツで１杯分すくっては
そこには魚はいないというですね
魚の存在する密度の
推定ができたわけです
つまり これは大きな発見ですよ
つまり このあまねく たくさん
どこにでも存在するような
そういう存在では
なかなかないだろう
結構珍しい存在だろうという
発見があったんだと思います
じゃあ 何でそんな珍しい—
宇宙が文明であふれている
そういうわけではないですよ
そういうのは なぜかと
言いますとですね
これ考えてみますとね
生命誕生しますね
多細胞になる
脊椎動物になって上陸して
哺乳類になって 霊長類になって
ご先祖様 というかこれ全部
ご先祖様ですけどね
お盆になるとこういう方々が
帰って来てるんですよ？
（笑）
来年からこういうのを
お迎えしないといけない
で いいですか
40億年前に生物が誕生してから
私たちに行くこの過程は
実は 無数の偶然が重なっております
たくさんの偶然があって
ここまで来ているわけですよ
たとえばですね
１つわかりやすい例
ここからここね
哺乳類から霊長類のところです
ここね 実は１億年前 何億年前は
ずっとこの状態でした
我々のご先祖様は
それ以上進化できませんでした
なぜですか？
その時 地球を
支配していたのは恐竜ですよ
彼らが支配していたために
私たちのご先祖様は
ずっとこの状態だったんです
ところが 恐竜が絶滅したから
哺乳類が適応拡散して
いろんな環境に行った
その内の１つが
私たちのご先祖様「霊長類」
もしですよ
今から6,600万年前の
あの恐竜を絶滅させた
あの隕石がですよ
軌道がそれていたらどうでしょう？
もしかしたら 今でも
恐竜時代だったかもしれないわけです
この大学のキャンパスに
なんとかザウルスが歩いてたかもしれない
逆に もっと大きい隕石が
衝突していたらどうでしょう？
恐竜も絶滅しましたけども
私たちのご先祖様 霊長類も
絶滅していたかもしれませんし
もしかしたら 全生命が
絶滅していたかもしれないわけです
これがわかりやすい—
先ほど見ていただいた
進化の絵の中にある
無数の偶然の１つなんです
つまり 何が言いたいか
というとですね
まあ どこかにはいますよ
どこかには存在するけども
そんなにたくさんは存在してないだろう
かなりレアな存在だということが
今の（説明の）根拠ですね
ここまでまとめますね
宇宙のどこかには知的生命は
きっと必ず存在します
でも それは非常に
レアな存在ですよ
スーパーレアな存在ですね
進化が難しいからですね
知的生命までのね
そういうことがここまでの—
我々が宇宙を研究してきて
分かったことです
もしですよ
ここからは想像です
もし どこかよその星の住人がね
私たちのこの地球を見ていたら
ここまでの話は
見上げる話だったんだけど
今度ね 逆ですね
視線を転換します
もし よその住人が
私たちの地球を見ていたら
彼らの目に私たちは
どのように映るんでしょうか？
私たちは 笑われてはいけない
そういうように思うわけですね
15歳から悩み続けてですね
ようやく今 答えが出たように
私は思っています
［自分は特別な存在なのか？］
地球人っていうのは結局
大変にレアな存在ですよ
もし 私たちの隣の人が
困っていたら
手を差し伸べて
あげようではありませんか
私たちは お互いに尊重し合い
協力し合うべきなんじゃ
ないかと思います
なぜならば 私たちホモサピエンス
私たち地球人は
大変にレアな貴重な存在なんです
一人ひとりは
ここにいらっしゃる皆さんも
YouTubeを見ている皆さんも
一人ひとりは かけがえのない
大切な存在なんです
一人ひとりが奇跡の存在なんです
どうもありがとう
（拍手）